that's right
okay everyone to our Thursday demise
conference and as you've heard me say
before we do different things at this
conference one of them is students
presenting their proposal defense so
[Music]
presenting their plan for their research
and leaving us a presentation on it and
then we give them feedback and so forth
and then like the actual defense they
after this the student the candidate and
committee will go into one twenty three
and I guess they're gonna have to follow
some circuitous route because of
whatever's going on out there
anyway so our presenter today is he's
actually already dr. Chris hoaxster
because he has a Doctor of Physical
Therapy degree but one doctoral degree
is not enough so he's pursuing a PhD in
our program which is actually nice it
lets us fund him as a postdoc fellow
instead of a pre doc Bello in so he got
his DPT degree from Pacific University
undergraduate degree in biology from
Willamette so he works as a physical
therapist
he's also been involved with a company
having the title of director of
knowledge management and his informatics
research interests are in organizational
behavior and its impact on the
perceptions and decision-making
processes of clinicians and managers so
he's going to give us his presentation
thank you and thank you all for taking
the time to come today on this beautiful
day outside so we'll get you out as
quick as you can so my my dissertation
proposal my research ideas around the
the impact of context on how managers so
specifically the managers in physical
therapy practices utilize in
systems to make their decisions so to
start that process what I want to do is
kind of get you all in the mindset of a
practicing physical therapy manager so
if you will
envision this is you here you're a
physical therapist by training the
majority of your care your time in your
week is responsible for patient care so
over 50% of your time or like 100% of
your time is seeing patients full-time
in your spare time then you do your
management duties and that includes
things like personnel decision so you're
hiring and firing individuals
implementing corporate strategy looking
at the financial performance of the
business unit that you oversee doing
marketing so trying to get new patients
into your facility you're responsible
for ensuring patient satisfaction and
you're responsible for staff development
in addition you're responsible for
overseeing the clinical quality of the
care that your providers give and so I
bring this laundry list of information
here is is to say that a practicing
manager in physical therapy has lots of
masters which they serve and they need
to divide their time among lots of
different tasks that are very disparate
now if we take all these despair things
they have to do when we put around them
information systems now we have a whole
nother Malou that they live in
so this manager has to simultaneously
navigate practice management systems
quality management systems the internet
or intranet to find information on
policies and procedures that sort of
thing HR systems client relationship
management systems payer reports and
their various systems and oh yeah the
EHR so they're simultaneously when they
have questions doing all these various
tasks have to go to the spirit sometimes
unified but oftentimes the spirit
information systems to you to find the
information that they need to do their
job so if we now kind of hone in on
clinical quality that's the focus of
where I'd like to aim there are certain
systems in the PT world that they'll use
for this so they're sometimes just EHR
based reports and you might pull
information out of the EHR say through a
crystal report or something like that
that tells a story on clinical quality
more commonly in the outpatient side
which is kind of where I'm hoping focus
they do have dedicated quality
improvement
quality management systems there are
freestanding systems sometimes they
relate or interoperate with the EHR
systems many times they don't there are
a few registries very hyper focused
registries related to physical therapy
these aren't as robust as many of the
medical registries or the disease
specific registries oftentimes these
become really a repository so the data
goes in but often times the data doesn't
come back out to be used for improving
clinical decision making also they're
integrated dashboard so whether they get
this information and they pull it all
into something like a tableau or they
may have some hooks into the tableau to
their other systems to deliver up the
information or they made to simply do
manual reports Excel spreadsheets that
someone codifies by hand so there's lots
of different systems and in within the
different systems there's lots of
different variants of a single system so
I show all of this information to say
there's lots of masters this individual
is serving when we get into clinical
quality there's lots of variety in that
world and we need to understand what
that is if we hope to really better
understand how we can do it better
so that really gets to my clinical
questions so my clinical questions
started pretty broad at the top and just
what are those influencers of
prioritisation for these clinical
managers so what is it that makes them
do what they do and not do what they
don't do there are certain influencers
on their life from there if I can focus
it down and say okay let's all these
distractions now we have management of
clinical quality now we can start to
hyper focus down on some other focused
questions so in that box of clinical
quality I'm interested in what other
information needs so when they have a
clinical question around quality
whatever that might be we'll talk about
some specifics in a moment what
information do they need to make a
decision on clinical quality second
would be what are their facilitators and
barriers to actually using one of these
clinical information systems to answer
that question versus doing something
else to answer the question and then
more hyper-focus to that is what are the
contextual factors that maybe aren't
apparent to them that also influence
their use or this use of these systems
and that really gets down to the hyper
focus of what I like to emphasize so
I'll take you through kind of three
stages through the rest of my talk today
we'll start off with some definitions
specifically defining what I'm
my manager what I mean by quality and
the what I mean by user acceptance of a
system then we'll go through some aims
of my study and then with all these
specifics methods to finish out so we
talked about manager manager can serve
multiple roles we saw those different
stakeholders that they have to serve but
simultaneously there they're also
serving multiple roles manager means
different things or leader means
different things so mintzberg and the
seventy's recognized that leaders
oftentimes are serving three main roles
simultaneously so they're the
interpersonal leader they're an
informational leader and then they're a
decisional leader and we can describe
that a little more granularly to say
that interpersonal leader is more that
lee iaccoca the the figurehead the
liaison back and forth they're the big
headcheese you now have the information
leader who's responsible for monitoring
information disseminating it to the
masses and also being the spokesperson
for the company on what information is
most valuable and then you have that
decision leader who's making the
decision so that entrepreneur there
they're kind of handling all the
disturbances in the organization they're
the negotiator that sort of thing I
could spend an entire dissertation
research project just understanding what
it means to be a leader in physical
therapy so I chose the hyper focus down
really on the informational leader so if
we think of the manager as that that the
holder of what's important to the
organization of information how do they
see how they're doing on those metrics
that they the organization sees are
valuable how do they get information
back to the frontline practitioners to
know how they're doing and they have to
lead in that so I left the leader piece
up there as well but really leading with
the focus on the information that
they're trying to get to the masses so
from there if we pause and we go off to
now what do we mean by clinical quality
because we're now defined what's a
manager now we have to define what do we
mean by quality if they're gonna be
managing quality and this is really
contingent on what stakeholder you're
talking to so these groups aren't
usually exclusive but we know that each
of these groups has a area of kind of
tacit focus that if they exclude all the
secondary things their main focus will
fall
kind of in this area so patients being
service quality we've got lots of
anecdotal settings of of patients that
like their care even if they don't get a
good outcome but they felt cared for it
was a nice office that people were
friendly they liked being there they
felt valued where maybe a provider has
more of a focus on did I do the right
thing did I do the right thing with
skill so it's much more of a a tactical
skill based now not that they don't care
about the surface quality that's
certainly important but a main focus may
be more on the technical skill of the
thing that you deliver in your specialty
and then we have the payer who now is
going to be the arbiter of the money so
they're not the this may be a private
payer this might be you the taxpayer
being to payer through the federal
government or this might be the
individual is also a pair if they're
cash paying for their services but now
you put in to say yeah I want you to
have great service yes I want you to get
get the best quality care as defined by
the best service but also we need to do
it for the least amount of money
possible and then finally you have the
organization basically if you think of
it from a business center they have to
please all of these individuals so if
you don't have happen patients you're
not going to be in business if you don't
have anybody to pay the bills you won't
be in business and if your providers
don't enjoy working for you you won't be
in business so they have to make sure
that each of these individuals is being
served so this puts the manager in an
interesting mediator role so they're the
face of the organization to the
day-to-day operations this individual
has to help figure out what are the
needs of those stakeholders and ensure
those needs are being met so that's from
the quality standpoint where the manager
sits is in that middle role but part of
my research is really going to focus on
where do you focus right now and then
more importantly why do you focus there
so first defining what it is but then
second is why why do you feel you do
that what are the stakeholders that are
influencing that what are the
organizational structural things that
are making you focus on that aspect of
quality so we'll pause at that point and
now go into technology acceptance so
we've talked about a leader we've talked
about quality and now we need to talk
about use of a system because in the end
Mike
question is a leader leading quality or
managing quality by using a clinical
information system so there have been
multiple studies on how do we define
acceptance of Technology most of these
models have drawn back to the work of
the theory of reasoned action which
basically is a psychological methodology
or a matrix that says ultimately we have
an attitude towards a behavior coupled
with what the people around you think
about that behavior and if both of those
things agree that you should do that
behavior then you'll probably intend to
do that behavior and then if you intend
to do that behavior you probably in the
end will actually do that behavior so
it's this behavioral intention flow so
you think it's a good idea to people
around you you think it's a good idea
which makes you want to do it which
makes you actually do it they kind of
step through that way now they've
studied this model in isolation and
they've said okay we we have the same
predictors up here and then a lot of
other models have tried to say well what
do we have back here that can predict
the attitude or what do we have back
here that can predict the subjective
norms and so we have individual beliefs
and also your past experiences with that
activity that better your background
that shape your attitude and then we
also have the same sort of thing the
organization their experience with that
activity in the past and that shapes
their subjective norms and those
together collectively all work to
influence whether you think you should
do that activity or not and they've
studied this with respect to use of
technology both in the consumer world in
the business world and in healthcare and
have shown that this can predict with
decent predictability so between 20 to
40 percent of the variance can be
explained by this model if we look at
use of various systems and we look
specifically in healthcare but what was
attempted was to say can we take that
model and refine it and make it a little
more specific to to technology this is
not specific to technology this is any
behavior so now this is specific to more
technology if you see here we have this
attitudes towards behavior that's the
same thing we had right here so the
technology acceptance model said we're
really going to focus on this one we
don't think subjective norms are as
important this one's more and
so can we work on some predictors of
that and so what they came up with as
their base model was that if an
individual thinks that a system is going
to be useful for their day to day jobs
or it's gonna have good performance and
they think it's going to be fairly easy
to use those two things together will
make them think it's a good system which
in the end will make them want to use
the system which will make them use the
system that's Tam and then they tried to
put lots of external factors back here
again to just say can we predict these
two main constructs that we think are
driving their intentions into the system
and this did a bit better so now we're
getting up into the order of 40 to 50
percent predictability of using the
system but this is one of many competing
models and so now what's happened over
the last 30 years is lots of researchers
and business folks have said we think we
can do this better by adding lots of
different things out here or tweaking it
just the right way and all of those have
had varying degrees of success or
improving the variability but now we
have about 14 competing systems all of
which that are trying to measure the
same thing which is using some sort of
technology so here's where it gets a
little bit crazy that ultimately we have
those same three factors here the
perceived usefulness ease of use
behavioral intention and system use but
this is the third version of Pam now
we've added all of these extra factors
these antecedents that predict back here
lots of moderating effects back here and
this only gained us one to two points of
a better explanation of the variance so
the models become much more complex but
it's not explaining the use much more so
we've lost some of that parsimony little
bit what we're trying to get out a model
and so this kind of brings me down to
the model that I'm trying to use for my
study the reason I show you this
background information is there's lots
of models I could have choosen chosen
for for studying the use of technology
the unified theory of use and acceptance
of technology I'll only say that word
once now we'll say you tout after that
so you tout basically said can we take
these fourteen competing models which
all kind of look like this but are
slightly different and we all boil them
down to some common constructs try to
make it a little simpler and can that
still do a pretty decent job of
explaining the variants that
of the use of the system so this is the
Utah model here in its simplest form
basically says we have that same
performance expectancy here that's just
like on fam we have effort expectancy
here that's just like on Tam they added
back in social influence because a lot
of the other models did say where you
work and what the people around you say
influences your decisions and also they
added in individual facilitating
conditions so things like if we give you
training to use the system are you more
likely the user if we incentivize you to
use the system are you more likely music
if we give you nice computers that
aren't kind of archaic and hard to use
but will that make it easier to use the
system so we can add lots of
facilitating factors as well as habit so
just if you've done it for a long time
are you more likely to keep doing it or
thinking that you should do it just
because it's the Rope thing that you've
been doing interesting thing is this you
taught model explained between forty to
sixty percent of the variability of use
of the ultimate system in the end what
they did in their second version is they
added an effect modifier so simple
things like age gender experience and
then also habit as an effect modifier
didn't change the base model at all just
basically put in these other interaction
terms and by adding those he increased
up to about 70% explain it without power
of of the end use of the system or
behavioral intention and so my
contention here is we can take a simple
model but then we can add some factors
around that that we think influence how
that model operates in real life and
that'll make the model a better
predictor in that area that you're
studying and this is a concept of
contextualization
of a model and we'll talk about that a
little bit so that contextualization
comes back to this common thing that
we've all seen in our introductory
informatics course that the concept that
an individual thinker plus a computer
system is going to net us a better
outcome than the individual thinker
alone or the compare alone so that
interface between them needs yield us a
good outcome this is only partially true
this is great but this doesn't happen in
a vacuum so this same process of person
interacting with the computer happens
inside of what we call this
socio-technical model so this individual
is using a system but they're you
they're a different type of person they
have characteristic traits that they
bring to the table they are in a system
that has a certain structure an
organizational hierarchy and incentive
structure a social structure they have a
specific task that they're using the
computer for so this process isn't gonna
be the same for all tasks and then
ultimately they have different
technologies every technology isn't
created the same so it's really the
interface between all of these four
factors the person the system the
structure of the organization that they
work in and the task with which they're
for which they're using a system all of
these things interact together to then
predict how this person is going to use
a system or the effectiveness of a
system in the end now what's been
studied a lot have been people in
technology
most of the TAM research really has
looked at an individual using a very
specific information system and how can
we predict that what they haven't looked
at are these other two factors of you're
using it for what or you're using it in
what sort of setting and these are
really the contextual factors that are
intriguing to me is I can take the same
person in the same technology but put
them in entirely different organization
and that predictive power is likely
going to be entirely different or I can
take the that same person in the same
organization but give them an entirely
different task and their performance is
probably going to be different so we
need to really understand all four of
these factors and I'm really interested
in the task and the organizational
structure for that so that really gets
me to my aims and the aims of this
really are threefold so we start with
the first one these all have contextual
connections so the first one would be a
task context and really what I'm
understand interested in understanding
is what are the information needs of the
managers and what are their seeking
behaviors right now to answer those
questions so that's not been studied in
the literature at all for
physical-therapy managers it has a
little bit for health care managers but
not much at all and then maybe a little
bit more for practitioners so medical
practitioners understanding their
information
behaviors but first of all we just need
to understand what questions do you have
what are the stakeholders around you
that are shaping those questions and
shaping the the way that you're managing
clinical quality and then how you go
about answering those questions or
coming to your decisions in your day to
day work if we can understand that then
we need to understand the organizational
context so what is it that you perceive
and things you don't perceive that can
facilitate getting those answers that
you need and really managing clinical
quality as you define it or one of those
things that are barriers to that that
are slowing you down or keep getting you
off-track and not allowing you to manage
quality to the way that your
organization defines it and I use that
term as you define it a bit loosely
because physical therapy unlike in
medicine has kept a relatively loose
definition of quality so medicine has
congealed around some of the meaningful
use concepts than we have in qf & arc
and those sort of things that have given
some specific measures that are specific
to medicine many of those don't apply to
physical therapy so physical therapy has
a few of those but they've also
developed a lot of their own so just
like they have lots of varying systems
to measure quality they have lots of
different measures of quality that
aren't congealed around common themes
and so in these organizations it's not
my intent to understand what's the
empirical definition of what should be
equality for physical therapy it is what
do you define as quality and how does
that relate to other organizations but
once you've defined it how are you
managing it and how are you using
information systems in the act of
management and then the last one here is
to understand this Utah system it's not
been studied in managers of physical
therapy it's frankly never been studied
in physical therapists in isolation it's
done therapists which have been pts OTS
and speech therapists in hospital
settings it's never been worked out in
the outpatient setting so really I need
to understand is it even applicable to
the setting of physical therapy and we
can really do that two ways we can do it
qualitatively and we can do it
quantitatively and I'll talk about that
it means but I'm really interested in
understanding how the manager kind of
operates in their day what are their
question
and how do they go about answering those
questions and making decisions how does
the context of the organization affect
that behavior and then how does that
maybe relate or not relate to the you
toute constructs that we showed here a
few slides back so these first two will
combine together in my first phase
there'll be a two phase mixed methods
study first two will combine together
into one phase and then this third one
will will span both phases and I'll show
you how in a moment here so what I need
to do though before we get into the
methods is just to talk about
contextualization of a model that is the
aim of what I'm trying to do is
understand how I can take this
freestanding and previously validated
model of you tout and contextualize it
for physical therapy managers in the
outpatient setting so the idea of
contextualization of a model is you have
some base model we'll take you to our
base model so you have that model living
in isolation but now you put it into
practice so you add certain task context
to that model so do using some sort of
software for some thing that's your task
and understand how does that influence
how the model behaves compared to how it
may have behaved in the literature in
another setting and then we also put
that task inside of the environment of
an organization and then try to
understand the influences of your
organization on that model and how do
those influences change the model so
first of all I just need to understand
does it still work when I put it in that
environment that's kind of my main focus
aim but then an exploratory aim would be
can I also play around with what happens
when we add certain factors that come
out of my first phase how do those
affect how the model behaves in this
setting so the way we'll do that we'll
have again a mixed method study will
have both quantitative and qualitative
aims so phase one hoping to take about
six months to do this we're using rapid
qualitative inquiry so rapid qualitative
inquiry is a qualitative ethnographic
method that's team-based so what this
allows us to do is take a team of eight
individuals that we've established that
have different
gives different experiences and
different expertise in addition to local
co-investigators so as we go into these
organizations we've identified or I have
identified a navigator to each
organization that we can check our
inferences on so we're thinking this
we're seeing this we're hearing this
does that make sense what aren't we
asking that you you think is important
they can give us an insider's
perspective
so what rapid qualitative inquiry allows
us to do is start with one main
methodological focus but as we learn
more information we can shift just a
little bit to explore these emerging
themes that come up so our methods are
fairly set at the beginning but they're
flexible to allow us to explore new
areas as they come up so how we do that
is we use propose of sampling of
managers and other leaders in the
organization both those that lead
quality as well as more the executive
level that are setting strategy at a
bigger level as well as observations so
can we observe these managers using
their information systems or however
they're answering their questions or
making their decisions on clinical
quality can we watch them do that and
ask them questions about that process
it's an iterative approach so we'll go
in with some themes we'll test those
themes will come out and what did we
learn what do we need to change and
we'll go back in and test those again
come back out what did we change what
have we learned what do we want to test
the next time we can go in and out both
within one organization but also between
organizations as well and I'll show you
a minute how we've broken down these
organizations this uses the grounded
theory approach as its core so we go in
somewhat blind saying we'd like to in
truth know graphic fashion we'd like to
go in and experience what it's like to
be you in your job and we'll draw some
themes based on that experience of
talking to you and watching you but also
we can use you tout as a bit of a base
themes us that we can seed some of the
questions and some of our base
inferences on themes can be well we
think probably they're going to talk
about systems being easy to use we think
they're probably going to talk about
systems serving their needs they're
going to talk about social influence
we may not overtly push that upon them
but we're going to be listening for that
and looking for that and that's how we
can still keep a ground if they're
Theory focus but also test whether you
Tao is
showing up in what we're hearing and our
inferences and then at the end we use
member checking so we go back these
individuals when we say here's what we
heard here's what we're thinking how's
this sit with you what did we miss and
what do we need to check for next time
so we get again on our perspective which
is now team based which makes it broader
than what I could do on my own but also
now we get their input that also shapes
our themes so if you think about what
we're doing in a truly quantitative
study I could pose a hypothesis I could
set methods and I could start here and I
could test my methods straight down and
get to the end in a very linear path
what rapid qualitative inquiry allows us
to do is to say I'm starting here with a
kind of an idea what I might see but I'm
leaving it purposely open and now we're
gonna explore on our first site a bit of
a methodology but about 2/3 of the way
through we might say we totally missed
this we need to look at this over here
because we didn't even consider that in
our first theme creation so now we do
site two that's informed by what
happened with site one so now we change
our methods slightly and change our
focus we can do that through each of the
sites and what that allows us to do is
rather than a nice clean straight path
which would be free of bias which would
get us there quickly which would take
away confounders which is all great but
it also that's at the expense of
understanding the breadth of the
information that we could get out of the
organization and so what rapid
qualitative inquiry allows us to do is
to be rigorous in our methods but still
get breadth of information we're not
trying to get rid of bias but we're
trying to understand that bias is there
and can release shine a light on it and
understand why it's there and that will
shape the things that we create so these
are the organizations that have leaned
in to participate so there's five
organizations I chose five organizations
of different sizes because there is at
least some literature that says bigger
organizations have different information
needs than very small organizations or
potentially rural organizations have
different needs than urban organizations
so we chose organizations with 800
facilities nationwide all the way down
to a practice in the northwest with
three practices and then folks in the
middle we have some that are rural some
better urban OHSU has agreed
so we have a hospital-based system and
then some private practices as well so
we tried to get a variety so that we can
understand what is kind of the breadth
of practice of outpatient physical
therapy in the US and then we don't get
hyper focus just on one organization
that may have its own limitations and
failure to have generalizability so
that's phase one to understand those
information needs understand the
facilitators and barriers to using these
systems and see if Utah basically fits
in a qualitative sense into would be to
now specifically go out in a
quantitative focus to say does it
actually empirically fit based on data
that we can look at from participants
the way we can do that is through a
survey so we can survey six constructs
of Utah so those are based upon twenty
three questions that have already been
validated in past research so there's a
questionnaire that a lot of the
developers of Utah have used and follow
up literature to test the constructs of
youth out so we'll take those 23
questions if we get some constructs that
come out of phase one that we think are
interesting and we think might be
contextual factors that we'd like to
explore then we can feed those in as
well all of these will be measured on a
seven-point Likert scale and then
they'll also be demographic questions
that allow us to do some of the again
effect modification but also just look
for differences amongst different aged
individuals gender individuals different
experience levels and organizational
size in past research these have all
been shown to affect how the other model
performs so the way we'll do this plan
on using structural equation modeling so
specifically covariance based structural
equation modeling there are some
assumptions with that form of structural
equation modeling so I don't know what
the day is going to look like until I
get it back from the surveys if it comes
back and it's really skewed or really
non normal and we can't transform it or
I get a very few number of responses
back we may have to use another version
which is called partially Squared's
which is a nonparametric approach they
would allow me still to get inferences
just over the less rigorous test of the
validity of those inferences primarily
it's a confirmatory based approach what
I want to look at again is does the base
model view
outfit with managers and physical
therapy but we'll also have an
exploratory aim at the end so if some of
the questions that I seed from phase one
have decent psychometrics I can feed
them back into the model and see if they
do have an effect on how the model
performs and then I'd also like to hold
out a portion of my data so 50% of the
data will be held out to do
cross-validation to make sure that as I
fit to this model I don't over fit we
can come back at the end and make sure
that it still fits in that hold out data
so again this is the base model that I
like to test this would be the primary
aim of the second phase of my research
is just to say does this actually work
without patient managers and physical
therapy so then you'd ask yourself well
why are you using structural equation
modeling because it seems pretty
straightforward that if I have this I
could just use multiple linear
regression modeling and it'd be a little
simpler way to do that so basically we
just get if I just took performance
expectancy an effort expectancy I can
just put beta weights onto each of these
maybe I add societal influences and all
my other ones add them all together and
I can predict behavioral intention the
problem is this is a unknown latent
construct so we can't actually measure
effort expectancy I can't just go in and
say how hard is it for you to use your
system that's maybe only one component
of effort expectancy so another way to
think of this is maybe we will use the
concept of depression to make this more
generalizable to something clearer to
everyone so you can't just ask a person
are you depressed that's one component
of depression but there are multiple
factors of depression that each can be
tested with a different battery of tests
so we put all those battery of tests
together we can now from all of those
infer okay this is a level of depression
that a person has but that actual
depression isn't directly measurable
just like these so we have to have these
questions that I can ask in a
questionnaire that we think loosely
relate to this but don't totally relate
to this and that's what structural
equation modeling allows us to do is
simultaneously test this outer
measurement model of how do the
questions relate to some common
construct that we think they should
relate to but then also how do these
latent constructs relate to one another
in a path model to predict some sort of
outcome down here which is in this study
going to be their intention to use the
system
not actually looking at the actual
system use because each system is
different we can't actually study logs
in all of these organizations at this
level to do that and you would need a
longitudinal study to look at that I
don't have the time and the resources
within the confines of my dissertation
to do that so we're looking at
behavioral intention which is fairly
predictive of actual use in past studies
so we're going to focus there this would
be more the exploratory phase so if we
show that that one model works or if it
doesn't work but I have some other
factors I can try then I'd like to take
factors that I find in Phase one so was
there something that we thought was
really specific about the task of a
manager managing quality that we could
feed into this system into the the
interactions and find out if it has an
effect on the model or are there some
things we heard about organizations
really big versus small organizations or
different leadership styles or incentive
strategies are there other things we
could potentially feed in to see if they
impact how well these already
established factors predict behavioral
intention also sticking in here system
satisfaction there's some research to
say that performance expectancy and
effort expectancy can relate to system
satisfaction even if they don't relate
to the Haverhill intention so it might
be interesting to explore down here if
these don't actually directly predict
behavior intention like you think they
do do they at least predict system
satisfaction so it just gives me some
other places to explore which really
doesn't give me perfect answers but
gives me now the next step of where I'd
like to go in future research to explore
these a little more empirically so the
way we do this is through a sample
survey sample so I can send out email
invitations the organizations that I'll
be using in Phase one
there are 900 managers as part of those
organizations so we'll invite all of
them to complete the survey I'm also a
member of the American Physical Therapy
private practice section that has 4,000
members that I have access to the
mailing list we can send them an email
survey invitation as well as I'm
presenting my phase 1 results next
November hopefully I've submitted
hopefully we'll get in I'll be able to
present there that'll be at least
another aspect where I can do a platform
call to save we've at least here's the
information from phase 1 of my research
and if you'd like
participating phase 2 here's a way that
you can do that so that give us a total
of potential 5,000 invitations that go
out assuming we only get tame the 40
percent response rate that leaves me 500
to 2,000 surveys to deal with now you'd
ask yourself is that a good number is
that a bad number if I get an offer your
Sam power calculation and it said based
on the number of indicators I have I
should be okay power analysis with
medium effect size with 237 responses so
why do I have 500 mm again
cross-validation I'm going to take half
of those out to be able to cross
validate so now we're down to that on my
lower end down to 250 there's also
within the SEM world than this rule of
thumb or the rule 10 that basically
would say you need to have 10
observations for every one of the
factors that you have so that gets me in
the ballpark right here and the last
piece is there's been a couple of
studies that have done X priori power
analyses comparing to what your opry or
e power analysis said and most SEM
studies are woefully underpowered and so
oftentimes this happens when your data
isn't perfectly normally distributed or
it's a bit skewed or you have some
covariance that you didn't account for
outliers and we know that's probably
going to happen with a Likert data that
I have and so we may need to have higher
sample size just to pick up differences
there so that this tells me that number
is probably in the ballpark of where we
need to be so limitations to wrap up
here this is looking at planned versus
spontaneous behavior so it's really
looking are you planning to use your
system there's lots of spontaneous
things that happen in life that we can't
account for through these questionnaires
so I'm looking more at their plan than
you're going also it's focused on
behavioral intention and not the actual
behavior of using the system's again I
don't have the time nor resources to
study their actual system use for this
phase of the study this is more
exploratory making sure the model fits
and I'd love to extend it at a next
level to look at this longitudinally to
see do they actually use the system or
better yet can we intervene with some of
the recommendations that might come out
of this study can we take a a
organization look at how they're using a
system now intervene and see can we
change system use by applying some
the things we learn here the model is
focused on an individual's action and
not a group action we're taking a leap
in that socio-technical model to say
that individuals action is shaped by the
organization and that individual is
representative of all people in the
organization but we know that an
organization is its own beast and we're
not studying the organization as a whole
and so we'll get some individual biases
nesting problems with us as well we know
that limited out to outpatient PT and
primarily in the northwest
so generalizability would have to be
checked this is very hyper focused on
where my study is going and this is also
a cross-sectional design so all the
limitations come with non longitudinal
studies we'll have to temper my security
of my inferences based upon this and
then this is also phase one is based
upon organizational interviews we're
having a navigator get us in we're
interviewing individuals in their
organization so they may feel less than
open to give all of their opinions they
may feel they have to give more of a
positive light of their system than
actually is there so we just recognize
that might be there and then on the
survey it's a self-reported survey so
that may not be the actual person's
intention they may not have paid
attention there may be psychometric
issues with the questions all that stuff
comes from a survey data and then last
is there's limited theory on which to
ground phase one and so that's why we're
using the ground to theory approach
because we want to create theory around
this but it would be nice to have a
little more Theory to test we don't have
that right now so we're creating it but
it is a limitation of the study so last
year this is kind of my timeline for
doing this phase one I hope is to start
some pilot testing in the next few weeks
just to make sure that our methods kind
of makes sense
IRB is ready to go hopefully we'll
submit that in the next week or two so
we'll be able to get into full data
collection in April and run that through
the summer within the nice thing with
rapid qualitative inquiries were
analyzing while we're collecting data so
there won't have to be a separate and
big analysis phase here at the end
there'll be some but a lot of that
analysis will be done iteratively while
we're going through the process then
write that up at the end of the year for
2019 he's starting some phase two
processes while I'm still running phase
one so
and the design of the survey is mostly
done now because it's based on past
researched study our survey but there's
there'll be some some extra questions
that I'll cede to that so we'll need to
do some face bulletins testing on that
so we'll do that in august/september and
then hopefully disseminate the survey in
october/november and then do the
analysis from December to April and then
run it up to the end to hopefully
graduate by next June so the last bit
here is just to thank my funding sources
of the foundation for physical therapy
and then the National Arbor medicine
training grant as well as to thank my
committee and other individuals that
helped me kind of shape research I guess
since I have the microphone oh that's
the first question a very very nice
presentation and interesting I'm trying
to get a sense of I mean understand the
value of elucidating aspects of the
physical therapy managers environment
where would you see take let's say you
understand that really well and its
really useful informative to them where
would you take this approach these
methods Bend physical therapy managers
yeah so my initial focus when I started
all of this a year and a half ago was
actually on the frontline practitioner
most of the research has really looked
at a frontline practitioner and how do
you manage quality and I still think
that's really necessary but I my
suspicion is that that individual is so
heavily shaped by the socio-technical
system in which they work that studying
them in isolation would give me
confounded results and so if I can
understand this piece now I can use
those as some kind of base setting
factors to say great I need to find some
organizations that look like this
because my past research said this is a
type of organization that affects the
model and maybe one like this and one
like this and then we can now look down
at the provider level to see how they
utilize the information secondly the
American Physical Therapy Association
started a registry about four years ago
that no-one uses right now absolutely no
one uses it's the only PT based broad
collecting registry that there is in the
nation I would like to help them with
the process and we've understood here
are some implementation things that can
help people want to use these systems
that are so robust and so well made but
they're not operationally fit into their
work system so can I learn from this
model to create an implementation
process that we can now as you implement
a registry in ten organizations study
that if we use these steps that we think
we'll get out of this for those get a
better implementation than if you don't
use them Thanks I was thinking about
your concepts of tasks in context and
trying to understand where people's time
fits into that kind of how when people
start to talk about time and this may
relate a little to Bill's question about
like how you as an informatics this
might try to eventually improve these
systems so that these tasks could
actually be done in these contexts that
you now understand better I'm curious
how are you going to ask them about time
and make sense of time as it relates to
the tasks or time that's available in
their context and to document that in a
way that it's able to be talked about
yeah so that effort expectancy speaks to
that someone loosely that's why the
qualitative methods really allow us to
explore that more I can almost guarantee
that as we go in folks will say it takes
me 20 minutes to get to the number that
I need to get to and that's why I don't
use the system I suspect that's going to
come out and if that comes out then then
we probably would no amount of
implementation is gonna help a poorly
designed system that this takes 20
minutes to get there now there might be
a training component that we have to
help them get there faster but that may
be assistant design things so I think a
lot of that would come back to if an
implementation system can help it great
but if not to the developers these
systems to say do you realize this came
out is the biggest theme that people
just aren't using your system because it
takes them too much time can we work on
finding ways to do this better or second
would be if there's competing priorities
I suspect we're also gonna see you that
these managers sit in this middle of all
of these competing tasks that come
flying at them
that they don't have any prioritization
over so it may go to the organizational
leaders and say you're individuals just
we know they don't have enough time to
do all of that and you haven't clearly
defined for them what's the most
important thing and what's the next most
important thing so that they can cut out
things that they shouldn't be wasting
their time on so make the system better
maybe some implementation training
things that can help them but I bet a
whole lot of organizational leaders and
there's some stuff you can do at this
socio technical level that will make
your social system more conducive to
getting things done faster
good job Chris would you go back to your
slide that has probably number eight
again somewhere like 30 Oh slide 30 or
slightly like 30 I might not have the
same version that's the one yes so could
you help me understand how I'm looking
at individual facilitating conditions on
the bottom and I would have guessed so I
must don't understand what you mean by
that that I would have guessed that the
individual age gender experience inhabit
yes or am i misunderstanding what
individual facilitating conditions are
and how are you dealing with the
collinearity and the problems in your
model yeah so the well I'm the first one
first so this the individual setting
factors are things like did you get the
training that you need to use this
system do they give you the time in your
day to use the system so it really isn't
system related so you can't really speak
to performance or effort expectancy but
it's did they give you the things you
need in your day to use the system so
that's the definition of at least the
four factor or the four indicator
variables questions that they have to
serve it that's what they're getting at
now with respect to collinearity there's
going to be : in the area in here and
that's the idea of this latent construct
is the hope would be that these four
factors that feed into individual
facilitating factors all relate to one
another much better than they relate to
everything else and that will be one of
the psychometric tests that we have to
do is to understand
do we have discriminant validity that
those measures measure that latent
construct better than they just measure
everything else but part of what SEM
allows us to do is to look at that that
covariance and use that in our model
creation so so the individual
facilitating conditions is not loosely
defined variation at the individual
level
it's very particularly defined as
specific attributes at the exclusion of
those attributes over there
correct and really the idea of the
latent structure that we're using we
have a reflective model in SEM I'm not
saying that these four questions are
100% all-inclusive of the con
sect of individually for several
conditions I'm saying the opposite way
that individual facilitating conditions
would predict how you answer those
questions and so I'm not trying to say
my my questions are going to perfectly
define each of these latent variables
I'm trying to say latent variables all
kind of pain around these indicators
well what I'm getting at is yeah and we
will look at their moderation effect on
them too so that'd be one way to look at
it but we certainly could shuffle them
around and put age in there anyway if
explorers exploratory part doesn't
[Applause]